- This is Jeopardy!
♪♪♪
- Tom, I'll start with you if that's OK.
He's an NBA owner. A self-taught.
guitarist. And has guest-starred in
both "The Office" and "Game of Thrones."
- Hmm.
He's unhappy with his
boss and has no options.
Who is Aaron Rogers?
- Ding ding, that is correct.
Well done.
- That's a projection, Tom.
I've never said I'm unhappy with my boss.
- I said it, not you.
[Laughing]
- Aaron, he taught himself
algebra at the age of six.
He streams on Twitch under the
handle "TheBadOne23" and can sign his
autograph backward with his left hand.
- Phil, are you on Twitch?
Yeah, I think that's
my teammate, uh, Bryson DeChambeau.
- That would be correct.
Well done.
Bryson, this is one, this one's for you here.
- Oh, boy.
- He was a four-time All-America
selection, has the middle name
"Alfred" and is right-handed.
- Oh, my gosh.
I got no idea.
Um, I'm taking a complete guess on this.
I don't know why.
No way it's my partner.
Who is Aaron, who is Aaron Rodgers?
I don't know.
- It is "Who is Phil Mickelson?" actually.
- No way.
Did you know Phil is right-handed?
- Phil, you never told me that, you son of a gun.
- Bryson, I got, I got some news for you.
I hate to tell you this. Phil doesn't like you.
- I love Bryson.
What are you talking about?
I love the guy.
[Laughing]
- I didn't know that.
See, I'd be terrible at Jeopardy.
I'm more of a "Wheel of Fortune" guy.
- Oh, sorry, Aaron.
- No, that's not a knock on Aaron at all.
- Teammate infighting already.
I don't like it.
- OK. Gimme a break.
- That's what we want: division from within.
- I want to talk trash to somebody in this group.
So if it has to be Bryson, so be it.
[Laughing]
- I've got one more question.
This is for Phil.
Phil, the answer to the question is,
we're looking for the question, but the answer is:
"He led the New England Patriots
to six Super Bowls, architect of one of the
greatest dynasties in the history of sports and is
known far and wide as the GOAT."
- Tom Brady is the GOAT.
They also call him the man.
Both seem to apply
and, uh, he's also my partner and I love it.
- Most importantly. Your partner.
- Can you form your answer in
the phrase of a question?
- Honestly.
- Question is: Who is the GOAT
but also known as the man.
And—
- Time's up.
[Beeper sounding]
- Yeah, honestly.
[Laughing]
- [Imitating buzzer]
That wasn't double Jeopardy, we'd be broke.
- Are you, are you saying: Who is Tom Brady?
- I'm saying: Who is Tom Brady?
- Ooh, no, Phil.
I'm sorry.
That would be Bill Belichick.
[Laughing]
I don't know.
How'd that go, Aaron?
I know you have, there's a little style
when there's an incorrect answer.
You don't want to shame the guy, but you
also want to make sure you get it right.
- Aaron, he was amazing, by the way.
- He was.
- A man of many talents.
Just like, just like everything else he does.
- I know.
- Phil, you probably didn't watch it.
It's a little too intelligent for you,
but, um, but thank you, Tom. ♪♪♪